A mí
eh nadie me VA a poner límites a la hora de defender
los intereses de Galicia.
Para mí Galicia está ante cualquier otra consideración
y desde luego
voy a ser 1 presidenta con las manos libres
ante el centralismo,
pero también ante las interferencias
de los grandes grupos económicos
que a veces se se sientan en el consejo de Asunta.
Yo lo estoy diciendo
y es 1 compromiso muy claro
con la ciudadanía y con 1 cambio de modelo energético
hay que quitar
la la silla que las eléctricas
tienen en el consejo de la Asunta
y vamos a trabajar
pues para poner la energía a servicio
de la sociedad.
Dicho esto,
¿cuál VA a ser el futuro después del 18 de febrero?
Pues lo tiene que decidir la ciudadanía,
es la ciudadanía quien define cuáles son los pactos,
porque esos pactos
eh se tienen que establecer 1 vez que los ciudadanos
hablen en las urnas
y creo que también hay que respetar su voluntad.
Es 1 experiencia
que si tú analizas los resultados en 4 años
es que le da 1 000 vueltas
a la gestión que ha tenido el partido
popular en 15,
o sea, nosotros hemos hecho en 4 años
más centros de día que el partido
popular en 15 o más escuelas infantiles
y sin embargo eh pues hemos perdido las elecciones
y eso pues ha provocado 1 crisis política
de la que nos nos hemos
levantado y nos hemos salido fortalecidos
porque de los Errores
también se aprende cuando 1 quiere
y esa para mí es eh 1 cuestión clave.
Siempre tenemos
eh que tener 1 sentido crítico con lo que hacemos
y debemos de ser humildes y reconocer
que no siempre acertamos.
Pero es cierto que se fue 1 gobierno
donde el Venega demostró
que tenía 1 proyecto de país alternativo.
¿De hecho hoy se sigue hablando no?
¿De qué importante sería 1 banco de tierras
para recuperar
nuestro 2º rural que realmente funcionara?
De poner la energía al servicio de la sociedad
y utilizar la energía eólica para hacer eh
desarrollos industriales en galiza.
Hoy seguimos viendo cómo,
pues el partido popular ha cortado
todo el desenvolvimiento de la política social
de vivienda o de la política
y de apoyo a las personas mayores,
¿donde se desmantelaron y separaron
todo el despliegue que se estaba haciendo
de centros de día
y de residencias públicas?
Bueno, yo si me dices eh, ¿qué balance hacemos?
Bueno, pues es que el balance le da 1 000 vueltas
a lo que representan estos 15 años del partido popular,
que son 15 años de retrocesos.
Es que yo
me pregunto, o sea, ¿qué ha hecho el PP en estos 15 años?
Si tú preguntas en Galicia
nadie es capaz de decirte
5 6 7 cosas relevantes
que haya hecho el partido popular por nuestro país.
Lo único que vemos es que nuestra sanidad está peor,
que tenemos menos profesorado y menos escuelas públicas,
que hay menos empleo industrial,
que Han Emigrado 200 000 jóvenes
y que tenemos eh pues 1 país donde la gente cree que
el futuro no está aquí,
que tiene que emigrar a buscar oportunidades.
Ese es el mayor fracaso de 1 sociedad,
pues nosotros lo que tenemos
no es la repetición de ningún gobierno,
nosotros lo que tenemos es 1 proyecto
que quiere construir 1 país
para la gente que quiere
defender nuestros sectores productivos,
que quiere poner la energía al servicio de la sociedad,
que quiere defender la sanidad,
el feminismo pensado desde galiza
y para ofrecer eh 1 proyecto donde esa mayoría
pues sienta como sienta su galleguidad
se sienta representada.
Creo que hace falta 1 Gran pacto por el gallego.
Tenemos que ser capaces
de unirnos
en defensa de algo que es nuestra lengua común,
que es la lengua de nuestras abuelas,
la lengua de mis padres
y que quiero que siga siendo la lengua
de mi hija y de mis nietas y por lo tanto
esto para mí es 1 cuestión eh de país
creo que es eh primero relevante,
que no permitamos los retrocesos que se Han producido,
¿no? De hecho
en galiza a día de hoy
está prohibido que puedan darse matemáticas
en gallego o física
año 2 023 y existe la prohibición
de que determinadas determinadas materias
en nuestro sistema educativo
se den en lengua gallega.
Y todo esto es 1 1 mensaje
que se le envía al sistema educativo
pero también al alumnado no,
porque se ha puesto el gallego en 1 esquina,
creo que tenemos que recuperar
1 papel de normalidad y de centralidad.
Lo tenemos que hacer
mano a mano con todos estos
los diferentes sectores del
que operan en el ámbito educativo,
pero también recuperando prestigio y espacios
para el gallego en todos los ámbitos.
¿Yo creo que esto es 1 proyecto de país eh?
Porque la lengua es eh
1 elemento que nos tiene que unir a todos y a todas
y donde tenemos que ser
capaces de construir ese consenso
para que no esté pasando lo que pasa en la actualidad.
Y es que los niños y las niñas que entran en el colegio
hablando gallego
salen hablando castellano.
¿Esto no? No podemos permitir que siga sucediendo,
pues yo creo que hay muchas fórmulas que se pueden
utilizar y es evidente que
eh tenemos que trabajar
para que se afiance el conocimiento del gallego